Improvements to accessibility in games
has become more of a focus over the
previous console generation
and thankfully great strides have been
made in opening up our favorite hobby
to many more people who require
additional considerations
in order to enjoy their experiences. Many
studios have dedicated
accessibility consultants in-house and
some games feature
options to tailor the experience to
accommodate for a raft of requirements
from high contrast options for the
vision impaired to offering alternative
control schemes for those with physical disabilities.
I spoke to Steve Saylor, content creator
and video game accessibility consultant,
and media editor at Can I Play That,
about what accessibility means
and the progress the industry has made
in improving it.
Generally it's usually described
as settings or options that make a game
playable for those with disabilities
whether you're blind, deaf or hard of hearing, or
have motor disabilities,
there are settings that kind of will
enable those players to be able to
remove some of the barriers that they
may have with the abilities that they have
so that they can be able to play the same game
as their friends are playing, with the
same challenge that they have
without a disability.
"Semi-auto rifle. Semi-auto rifle ammo.
Nine loaded. Nine reserve."
We really didn't see anything for
accessibility in any game
The very first Assassin's Creed
game didn't even have subtitles
subtitles whereas now when you look at the
latest version Valhalla, it has far more
accessibility options
than the first game did, and so
it took a long time to be able to get to
this point but it really kind of ramped
up within the past few years where
advocates like myself and consultants
like myself have been able to talk to developers
and encourage them to add these options
and talk to disabled players because
they want to be able to play those games
and not only is that sort of like a
good thing to do
but it also can translate
into sales as well.
Now when we're going into next gen
we're seeing a lot more awareness of
accessibility and whether that's in part
because The Last of Us Part Two this year,
or just the momentum in general our
conversations are
becoming more prominent and a majority
of people know about accessibility
and a lot of those people are developers
and they want to be able to try to make
their games
available and for everyone.
In recent years game developers and designers have
been more proactive about improving accessibility
and reaching out to advocates like Steve
who worked on The Last of Us Part 2
has been key to that.
However, fundamentally each console has its own
accessibility challenges that many don't
think about and require more involvement
from platform holders and the industry
at large to address.
In a twitter thread earlier this year,
Steve called the 100 dollar difference in price
between the disc and digital editions of
the PS5
are disability tax citing the
PlayStation store's inflexible refund policy
as an issue for many gamers with
accessibility requirements.
Obviously there are two different
versions of the PlayStation 5, you have the
digital and the disc version.
Generally a lot of disabled players
usually prefer to
purchase the physical copy of a game
mainly because a lot of the refund policies
if you purchase the game digitally
are not at a place yet
where they can be able to at least get
their money back. Because often times
whenever we have to be able to put down
60 dollars plus, that's a lot of money
for for some people to spend on a game,
and if a disabled player
pays that amount for a game, they take it
home and they play it,
and they realize an hour in
I can't play this, that's a lot of money
to be able to kind of
in a way be wasted, and if you
buy it digitally
oftentimes the refund policy is 'Well
you already downloaded it so we can't
give you a refund.'
Whereas if we buy it physically, at least
we could be able to
take it back to the store and even
though we can't get a full refund
we more likely can be able to trade it
in to be able to at least get some of
our money back. When it comes to
sort of the disability tax i had
mentioned with the PS5,
it basically costs in some cases
100 dollars more
to be able to have access to that.
Also the ability to be able to use
Game Pass as a selling point for the new
is a huge accessibility advantage, because
like I mentioned in regards to
sort of the disability tax, what's great
about Game Pass
is that you can be able to get games day
one of release from Xbox first party studios.
When you have the ablility to get
those games by paying a certain amount
per month, you could be able to download
those games day one
and you can play it try it out.
If it doesn't work for you and you're
not able to play it
you can easily delete it, download a new one
and you're not wasting a huge amount of money for it.
As consoles move towards an all-digital future,
and with accessibility features rarely
included in a game's marketing prior to launch,
subscription services such as Xbox Game Pass
become all the more important in ensuring that
gamers with individual requirements
don't end up unfairly out of pocket.
Playstation does offer Playstation Now,
but its library is by comparison
skewed much more towards older games and
unlike Game Pass
does not generally include new
first party titles upon release.
There's also the Playstation Plus Collection
but once again this consists
of last-gen games.
Until accessibility features are common
as part of a game's marketing,
or Sony changes their refund policy to
account for accessibility,
it may continue to be gamers with those
requirements who foot the bill.
There are also considerations to be made
when it comes to the hardware itself.
It's a mundane point but a larger,
heavier console, or one that requires you
to attach a stand with a small screw,
means that many people with physical
disabilities may find themselves unable
to unbox and set up their new console
without the assistance of someone else
which, given the world is currently in
the midst of a pandemic,
is far from ideal.
A headline feature for the PS5
is the brand new DualSense controller,
which features haptic feedback and adaptive triggers,
but these settings can be disabled on a
system level as well as individually in
titles such as Miles Morales,
which offers 'accessibility vibration.'
Frustratingly these additions mean that
the DualShock 4 and other PS4-compatible controllers
are not supported for PS5 games, which
will be a concern to those who have a
personalized setup
adapted to old hardware.
By contrast, Microsoft has ensured that any
compatible Xbox One generation
controller works without issue on the
Series X and S.
As with the Xbox One you can remap
buttons on a system level
and the Xbox Adaptive Controller is
supported, along with the Adaptive Gaming Kit.
Though Microsoft deserves plaudits for
being the only major company with an
official adaptive controller, and the
only one selling additional third-party
solutions on its site,
it should be noted that the controller
and kit could set you back over 200 dollars,
not including the external joysticks
that are required.
For the Xbox Series X and S
what Microsoft did was, they actually
took a lot of what they had
already developed internally and refined it
for next generation. So if you're coming
from an Xbox One
and you're using the
accessibility settings
in the ease of access menu in the Xbox
it's the exact same
ease of access menu on the Series X and S
and so you're going to get the same
experience. That's on the Xbox side.
On the PlayStation side actually, what they
did was kind of interesting.
There's pretty much the same
settings that is on
PlayStation 4 is on the PlayStation 5.
They have also
kind of enhanced a lot for blind players
Before there was a text-to-speech option in the
PlayStation 4
that unfortunately was only available in
English only. But now with the
PlayStation 5
they've enabled screen reader to be available
in multiple languages across the world, so
you can be able to turn on the console
from day one when you get it, and it will
guide you through the setup process and
you can be able to keep that on
throughout the rest of your setup.
"Fast 2. Fast 3."
It's an amazing way to be able to
kind of navigate the system and it works flawlessly
across the entire operating system of
the PlayStation.
"Voice type. Voice volume."
When it comes to sort of like the DualSense
controller that I have here
with the haptic feedback it basically
adds a lot more immersion for blind
players as well,
where the precise and subtle details of
the vibrations in the controller
actually help blind players to be able
to feel the environment that they're
in, and know when they're walking or when they're
being attacked, or when things are kind of
moving from side-to-side,
and that along with the 3D audio
that's built into it is
a really amazing feature.
Actually PlayStation has a
neat little feature in it called Game Presets
where any game you play will
automatically turn on
whatever difficulty setting you want to
be able to set,
whether to turn on subtitles,
or to invert controls,
and enable settings that you normally would have to
turn on whenever you start up a game for
the first time.
I'm really excited to be able to see
what else that Sony and
Microsoft can be able to do
moving forward now that accessibility
is kind of built in
from from the ground up.
It's clear the industry has come a long way
in the past 10 years in recognizing the
challenges that some people face
just to be able to play games at all.
But hopefully this is the beginning of a
progression towards a future
where all games are open to everybody
no matter their individual requirements.
As far as for Xbox what I'd love to be
able to see from them, and they actually
are doing that, is internally in their
studios they are pushing for
accessibility pretty much on every
single project that
every studio is working on in their Xbox game studios,
and they have an internal accessibility
team called 'Gaming for Everyone'.
I'd really love to be able to
see where that goes, and and I'm loving
what Xbox and
their initiatives have kind of done.
What I would like to be able to see
over the next
five to ten years for accessibility in games is...
I'm a content creator.
So reviewing games is kind of
what I get to do. I would love it for the
industry to get to a point where
five years down the road I can be
sort of nitpicking
certain accessibility options, instead of
just saying
"Why doesn't this game have some?"
That's what I would love to be able to get
get to that point, where every game
has a standard of accessibility
and we can be able to
open this genre or this art form up to
more people. I love what
Microsoft put out a couple of
years ago when they released the
Adaptive Controller,
and they used this phrase internally, is
"When everybody plays we all win".
That's something that we in the
community adopted,
and really tried to build a showcase
that games are for everyone
and games should be for everyone, and
accessibility is is a huge part of that.
Last year we spoke to Rod Fergusson
of The Coalition, who went into detail
about Microsoft's push for
accessibility features
among its first party titles.
You can check out that episode of Audio Logs
in the link below. For more information
on accessibility within gaming I'd
recommend checking out Can I Play That,
which offers in-depth accessibility
focused reviews of gaming hardware and
software, and there are a number of
charitable organizations like SpecialEffect
and The AbleGamers Charity dedicated to
enabling people with disabilities
to enjoy games.
For more on the past, present
and future of gaming keep it locked to GameSpot.